[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think it's time for us to talk about
zombies you're naughty everyone
especially all the zombies fans out
there we know who you are those of you
who remember zombies is a bonus mode
hidden in call of duty world at war have
been with us from the beginning you've
watched as our undead have grown to
become an essential part of the black
ops experience the story that we began a
decade ago is as much a result of your
work as it is a house zombies has always
been about that shared journey both
through our characters and the tightly
knit teams who and friends who joyfully
compete to be amongst the first to
uncover the most latest and deepest
secrets just as with the rest of black
ops war we've gone back to the drawing
board on zombies rethinking and we can
give you more ways to have fun with your
friends than anything we've made before
the zombies community has always been
our North Star which is why we took
everything that you've taught us and put
it on the table the discussion about
where to go to next 10 years after it
all began we're about to begin
a brand new chapter in the zombies story
right here together and we couldn't be
more thrilled to reveal the details with
those of you here in attendance and the
many fans tuning in worldwide
joining me to share more about this new
adventure is Craig Houston our lead
writer
[Applause]
hello so over the years what are the key
aspects that is driven the zombie
storyline and found interest is mystery
I sense that you're entering an unknown
world where anything can happen when we
say anything we mean anything you know
stuff like giant robots mythical staffs
interdimensional time travel and we
monkeys they explored when you throw
them maybe you're training monkey you'll
be fine
basically all the things that you zombie
fans consider normal we've explored many
different time periods and a variety of
fractured universes knows the perfect
time to start fresh and let the zombies
community discover a whole new world
together
black ops 4 marks the beginning of a
brand new storyline separate and
distinct from the ether story a new
world with new characters and new
enemies drawing from history both real
and mythical black ops 4 zombies will
introduce us to a new enemy an Ancient
Order hell-bent on transforming the
world to fulfill the nefarious agenda
against them stand an eclectic group of
all new player characters unexpectedly
thrust together by their shared
experiences with each one bringing their
own colorful personality skills and
unique perspective to the team you know
what it's probably best if I just show
you this is 9
[Applause]
you Hugo
[Music]
was not
[Music]
Green
[Music]
transport him
[Applause]
[Music]
for your safe return
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Garlits
Bruno Diego and sure our new cast we
know them and we can't wait for you to
get to know them too okay a mysterious
new world sinister villains and engaging
heroes and a riveting story of chaos all
forms just one half of the equation it's
the what will play now let's talk about
the how how we'll play the game during
the development of black ops 4 we
routinely ask ourselves the question how
do our fans like to play well after
taking down literally thousands of
zombies it turns out that you have
earned the right to make up your own
rules and play the game the way you want
to play it so we're going to provide you
with customizable tools and social
systems to evolve zombies into a
evergreen mode for daily weekly monthly
and yearly engagement zombies also now
boasts custom mutations over a hundred
different customizable options will
allow you to play the game your way
changing the fundamental rules and
systems of the gameplay experience
things like zombie speed health train
ability type player damage magic box
functionality and much much more and
since the zombies community loves to
compete with each other we're also
introducing the black ops authenticity
stamp system this will give players a
shareable code stating exactly what was
achieved and with what options as I'm
sure you can imagine this will help
third party high scoreboards and other
kind of custom competitions no one likes
cheats especially me on the subject of
custom compositions we're also
introducing limited time created
challenges that we're naming callings
which will regularly introduce new ways
for you to play the game and set the
stage for ongoing seasonal content and a
few themed experience surprises well on
the way and as we give our fans more
power on ways to play we'll aware that
zombies can sometimes be
a little bit intimidating to new players
especially those who like to kick back
on the couch and play solo the good news
is that black ops 4 zombies will also
include bot support meaning you can
enjoy the full narrative experience that
comes with co-op not got a buddy play
with let our AI fight alongside you want
to mix it up even more we're introducing
a new mode called zombie rush a brand
new mode simplifying the game experience
to create a whole new tempo of gameplay
perfect for welcoming people into the
zombies universe and enticing challenge
with grizzled veterans alike
we're also reintroducing difficulty
levels and an in-game tutorial to
introduce place to the mode in a less
stressful way for those of you also
choose to have the path of most
resistance you can crank up that
difficulty all the way up now speaking
of stress we've already seen our four
new heroes during an era of utter
brutality where no-holds-barred
winner-takes-all combat wasn't just the
rule of law but society's favorite form
of entertainment but zombie fans
wouldn't be interesting to see them go
somewhere nice somewhere luxurious
somewhere they could have a good time
it is my pleasure to show you a glimpse
of the second of our day one zombie
experiences
welcome to voyage of despair
[Applause]
[Music]
lady Mackendrick maybe at a higher class
than you are used to
mixing with her her Bruno my French
friend the lady will be so lost in my
eyes and enthralled in my tales she
would not even notice when I make my
move
[Music]
detective timing as always is everything
while you and lady McBrayer head off to
do whatever it is that you're going to
do sure will collect Sookie allowing us
access to the millionaire's sort well we
will deal with any unwanted guests but
when you say deal with I have to ask I
will not sure how you say jar of it's
Eve okay
and with you so far but what did you
call their pipe things you're looking
for a pneumatic tube used for the
conveyance of small packages throughout
the vessel they will carry how some
prize down the cargo it really should be
quite exciting
[Music]
and after the detonation that's where I
come in
given that the artifact will be securely
locked within the safe dare I ask how
you plan to get through two inches of
solid steel I got just the thing a
mechanism of my own invention what does
it do
it opens things
now obviously your father made some
enemies during his troubles that's a
pretty big understatement if I may
interject I think you were about to ask
if Miss Rhodes expected us to encounter
any opposition it's possible likely to
lose your valuables are we disap yours
I'm also just the artifact we're not
thieves we'll go with him all that
stands between humanity and the forces
of evil
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so that's what's happened so that's what
happens when you unleash the zombie
horde somewhere nice okay was the
Titanic but it should have been nice
trust me that bloody great icebergs I
mean the least of our characters worries
there is so much more to talk about and
this really is just the beginning we'll
be revealing a lot more later this
summer where we we shall share further
details on other never-before-seen
goodies on our road to release thank you
[Applause]
friends we're not done yet
you've seen a taster of nine and voyage
of despair but that's not all the
zombies news we have for you today we've
already said that black ops 4 is the
deepest most replayable game in our
history so it's my great pleasure to
reveal that for the first time ever we
will launch with three fully fledged
fully loaded zombies experiences on day
one we've seen a taste of what's ahead
in our new story but let's just take a
trip back through the ether one of our
all-time fan favorite maps told the
story of four lost souls trapped in an
eternal purgatory desperate to break the
cycle
here's a small peek of black ops 4/3
zombies map
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
where are
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]